[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum it's almost halloween
guys you're listening to inside of you
ryan is here yes uh thanks for listening
thanks for making me part of your day
i hope you're having a glorious week uh
please spread the word on the podcast uh
subscribe if you're uh if you're here
for ken marino and you just want to
listen to ken maybe you'll stick around
subscribe um that'd make me happy you
could follow us at insideyou podcast on
facebook and instagram at insideepod on
twitter which is right here and uh very
exciting i will be in denver
october 30th and 31st doing a convention
with tom welling signing autographs
i hope you will be there in denver
colorado october 30th and 31st
join me a big shout out shout out to my
patrons who i couldn't do this podcast
without uh if you want to give to the
podcast a little more keep us afloat go
to patreon.com inside of you i hope
you're enjoying the podcast um ryan give
you a week you went to a wedding i did i
went to a wedding uh some of my friends
from college got finally tied the knot
they've been together for a very long
time and did you cry i did you did yeah
during the um the toasts uh the parents
did you toast no i didn't toast no uh
but no the parent speeches kind of got
me because it uh yeah you sort of think
about time
my parents that they spoke i'd throw up
yeah i'd probably throw up i don't think
i
last
uh
great guest today ken marino you know
him from uh he's on a show called the
other two very funny guy wet hot
american summer party down uh burning
love he's been in so many things you're
gonna recognize this guy but he's got a
lot to say and i really loved him as a
guest um very open
very funny uh ryan so funny one of the
funniest people on the planet he is
really one of the funniest people on the
planet so
without further ado why don't we just
get into it
let's get inside of ken marino it's my
point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience you brought over some treats
today i brought over some treats yeah i
brought you some coffee you brought i've
never had a guest bring me anything this
is the truth i've never had a guest
actually you're like hey can i pick you
up a coffee well that's surprising to me
it is because uh from the shows i've
listened to a lot of the people well
have people come over recently um
we had uh we had your good buddy joe
latruglio and he was here he was here
and he didn't bring anything he did not
bring me anything all right i'll make
sure to let him know you should thank
you yeah no i'll hold that over his head
forever i've had some guests here um
really nice guest jennifer love hewitt
who she didn't bring me anything but
she's always very thoughtful she's
actually gotten me some guests before
maybe you could do the same after
whatever you need really for you you're
a
full-service uh i i mean not full
service but yeah i mean i can i can get
you some guests
you can
if you'd like i can
certainly like that we always like funny
people here
well i'll then i'll see if i can uh uh
you know wrangle up some funny people
that would be good yeah so your wife
explain this you have i have all these
you have a wife yeah you have two kids
what i mean that how much explaining do
you need there i don't need more than
that okay
but i will say that your wife you had
all these old tv guides we're talking
70s 80s that you've been collecting
since you were young well i collected
them when i was young and then they were
just sitting in my mother's basement and
then she said
hey
get this [ __ ] out of my basement and
your wife no my my mother your mother
said get the [ __ ] out of my baby yeah so
then i said well just send it to me
across the you know cross country
so then she
mailed
you know what were like hundreds of
uh tv guides from the 70s and 80s to my
home right at which point my wife was
like
what are these and i said oh they're tv
guys from the 70s and 80s and she said
what is this [ __ ] doing here get the
[ __ ] out of here so i immediately put it
in a
put them in a uh
a suitcase and hid them in the garage
because in my head i feel like i'm going
to do something
i'm going to do something with them
someday saying it out loud what are you
going to do sort of understand where my
where my wife is what were you thinking
of doing like what did you think they're
gonna be worth something someday
i don't know i just collected when i was
younger i collected mad magazines and tv
guides and i always enjoyed the tv
guides
especially i was telling you this before
like the the fall preview ones where it
was like special and they were like
colors uh you know like uh the whole
front of it was uh
all color print out because usually they
were in black and white but then on the
in the front where they usually do
interviews it was all colored printouts
of uh the new shows and then in the back
or in the front it was the shows that
were returning and then in the back it
was all the new shows that were
happening and it was great you could see
like you know
young
you know uh uh
prepubescent you know jason bateman in a
tv show that you'd never heard of
look at these yeah laverne and shirley
you you said you know
so you go around and you you bring them
when you see your friends you say pick
one now i've been so i thought well
maybe the reason i've been holding on to
them is to share them with friends
uh my peers people my my age or people
around my age who appreciate people who
are pre who who has who have a nostalgic
kind of feeling about them because
nowadays tv guide doesn't exist anymore
not like that right you don't you don't
you didn't look forward to getting the
tv guide every week to look at it
uh and look what was you know on the
four channels right it's different now
it was exciting it was exciting i mean
to me it was exciting and your wife said
get this [ __ ] out of here so ultimately
well you just get them out of my sight
my wife is wonderful she just doesn't
want me collecting uh a pile of
old tv guides okay 70s and 80s which
you know makes a lot of sense well this
also indirectly affects me
or directly affects me why is it how is
it because as you can look around my
house you notice i have a lot of things
that i collect now i'm you know i have
fangoria magazines and i have now some
tv guides yeah um yeah i have posters so
i feel like if i was if i were married
to your wife
well two mo if you were married if you
were married to anybody
they'd be like it's a lot it's a lot
but you're a single guy and so this is
the coolest
house i've ever seen because it's just
got like everything that you know
everything it has everything you love
and there's an overlap there's a lot of
things in here that i love and so it's
like i feel like i'm in a museum well
yeah it's delightful well it scares me
though why are you scared it scares me
because you're in your early 50s i am
you look fantastic by the way you look
the same as as you did when i met you we
could talk about that a minute but i
will say it scares me that i'm i'm
single i live alone i'm 49.
this is the same conversation i had when
i was 39
probably when i was early third but now
it's kind of it's like now it's is it is
it that is it really funny what's the
conversation well the conversation is
it's like you know
i'm about to hit 50 in a year i just
turned 49 yeah what did you notice did
you get depressed when you hit 50 when
you when you somebody you woke up in the
morning and you were 50 years old yeah
did that affect you at all no it didn't
no but you made a left turn here you
were talking about it happened when you
were 49 50 are you talking about like
when it hit you like because i thought
we were talking about
if if you got married
i don't know when you're planning on yes
but um
would your significant other
approve of this yes and then i st then i
say to myself i made that left turn
where i'm like am i kidding myself am i
actually going to ever get married or am
i going to be alone
it's both maybe right and so it does
scare me and i'm like it never age never
really scared me until i was like wait a
minute 50
you do think
older
i i don't i mean i do i mean i do a
little bit but i i also realize that
like
you know the cliche you're only as old
as you feel and age is just a number
those cliches
are there's there's value to them for me
in that um
somebody made up that there's you know
based on the moon and the stars and the
earth rotating there's 365 days in the
year so okay that's great and then every
year that's one year and then next year
is another year and but like none of
that who gives who gives a [ __ ] i'm just
alive or i'm dead
that's a really fascinating way to think
about it well i because i like i'm 50
i'm 49 i'm i'm i'm i'm i'm 60 i'm 30 i
feel
you know how people always say
i i don't feel 50 i don't feel you know
like i'm
like you know 70 years old i don't feel
like i'm 40.
yeah because
because it's a number it means nothing
how do you feel
i feel great i mean things hurt you know
i i'm going for a
a colonoscopy
tomorrow i'm going for a 3d image of my
heart
because i have high cholesterol on
thursday
um
but like i exercise and i try to uh
you know
approach life in a in a healthy way
uh for my mind and my body and
uh my spirit or soul um but you know i'm
i i i feel shitty and depressed some
days and i feel great other days
inside of you is brought to you by sonos
don't go anywhere sonos is the best
product out on the market right now i've
been using this for so many years sonos
sound system they're so in innovative
they're always coming out with new
things like the rome which i'll talk
about but i have music playing all
around my house i could play music in
each room different playlists in each
room um i don't know what i would do
what i would do without sonos anybody
who knows me um knows that i have sonos
machines all over the house and they
don't take much space at all they are so
small here's for instance here's a sonos
device here look at this and this
speaker plays unbelievably
clear loud as loud as you want um music
and uh i'm so glad they're a sponsor and
they've got this new product rome and
you need to hear all about it sonus rome
is the ultra portable smart speaker that
allows you to bring the sonos experience
everywhere you go rome weighs less than
a pound and its premium durable design
makes it perfect for the home and for on
the go and when you're at home roam
connects to your wi-fi network and the
rest of your sonos system and then
automatically pairs with your phone on
bluetooth when you're on the go
for a seamless experience using
automatic true play tuning rome smartly
adapts to your surroundings and whatever
you're listening to and creates sound
that astonishingly detailed and
perfectly balanced control roam using
the app apple airplay 2 or your voice
with amazon alexa or google assistant
with sonos you can start with one
speaker and expand your system over time
like i have all sonos speakers connect
over wifi so you can group speakers in
different rooms and play music
throughout your home i love sonos if you
don't have a sonos machine you're
missing out and all you have to do is go
to sonos
s-o-n-o-s-com to learn more
sonos.com to learn more you will not be
disappointed inside of you is brought to
you by geico ryan what do you know about
geico uh i know that they have been
around for a long time and they offer
some bundling policies that's true you
know like we always talk about you you
want to pay your renters insurance
homeowners insurance along with your
auto policy you want to make life easier
on yourselves guys geico is a trusted
name around the world and you can do all
that easy with their bundling policies
geico's bundling policy they make it
easy to bundle your homeowners or
renters insurance along with your auto
policy
we have too much going on around the
house too much time doing other things
to worry about paying all these places
so just do it with guy with geico it's
easy you just go to geico.com you get a
quote you see how much you can save it's
geico easy visit geico.com today that's
geico.com inside of you is brought to
you by m1 finance there's a reason they
call m1 finance the finance super app
this all-in-one app makes it easy as pie
to invest borrow and spend exactly how
you want build a portfolio of stocks or
etfs in minutes with their intuitive
pies interface or use a pre-build expert
pie that invests according to your goals
investing involves risk and m1 helps you
invest according to your risk tolerance
borrow against your portfolio with some
of the lowest rates on the market then
use it however you want keep in mind
borrowing increases your risk and rates
may vary or stash your cash in their
free digital checking account it's fast
it's easy and it saves you tons of time
and time is money
switch to a sleeker easier and better
way to manage your money plus get a 30
bonus to your m1 invest account when you
get approved and fund it with 1 000
within your first 14 days go to
m1finance.com
inside of you for more information
that's m as in michael the number one
finance.com
m1finance.com terms and conditions apply
colonoscopy i will say that a lot of
people say oh my god you got a
colonoscopy
i had a wonderful experienced
experience i i really did i when you say
a wonderful experience yeah i had this
drink they gave me these drinks yeah uh
early evening the night before yep i i
peed out of my bee
yeah and bp bp
and uh
i went to bed i woke up i mean it was it
was
it wasn't that intense and uh they put
me to sleep and i said doc i don't do
drugs but can i feel it for a few
minutes can i feel the anesthesia or
whatever i felt great and then i woke up
he said you got no polyps and i was done
yes and that was it so it was a great
experience for me i didn't you know i
got put to sleep i got to feel good well
it had a happy ending it had a happy
ending so
i'm just telling you you don't have to
worry if you're even worried i'm not i
had it one other time and i had the same
experience
except i asked i wanted to stay awake
for it
and look and see what they were looking
at
and then he's like well we can't do that
and he and he said he goes you can do
like you could ask for to like tw
something called twilight or something
like that where you're sort of in and
you're sort of out like
you know like you're not
but you're not asleep and i was like
yeah i want to do that and he's like
okay and then i went in and they gave it
to me and i immediately went out and i
woke up and i was done no twilight no
twilight jeez you know you you and i met
years ago
we were bowling
it was all your old buddies from the
state
okay um tom lennon and
uh
everybody joe is this when you for this
this is
i was
this is the first time that we've met
that we met or is this just one of the
memories
we met at around that time and maybe we
met in new york briefly i met you
through ballard through ballard right
but we used to start hanging out because
you guys are over and play poker at my
little rent-rented house and play video
games played sega right
and you played a lot of hockey and at
the time
you had hurt your back yeah or somewhere
in there you would hurt your back
from playing
hockey and probably sports my whole life
and a bunch of other [ __ ] and i remember
that you you you were
you had some back issues
that you were
dealing with suffering with yeah but i
remember like you guys used to oh you
and sarah silverman just name dropping
here and mike liam black and showalter
you used to come to my house and play
poker and you used to all take my money
i can't imagine that i did because i'm a
terrible poker player i just came for
the uh the camaraderie really yeah
because they took it really seriously
mike black took it takes it very
seriously joe is a good poker player
david wayne
very good sarah
she's a very good poker player but she's
just in it to have fun i think yeah
she's um
uh she's real good too although i went
to her house years ago she invited me to
play poker and i was so bad that she
never invited me back or i just wasn't
funny
i i don't think that's that's it i've
called her up and been like are you
having any games late you know
anytime soon and she's like oh i'll put
one together
so i bet if you reached out and said i
want to play any games i want to play
she'll try to throw something together
now what i remember about you though is
you always had this
i don't want to say swagger but you
always were confident you always seemed
really confident
and poker no in life
in life you felt i felt like ken
just
is exudes this confidence now what i
want to know is it's something that you
always had like if we rewind the clock
back to grade school in high school you
were a confident kid no you weren't no i
mean i think i had to i well i don't i
don't
i don't know if i'm
i don't see myself as super confident
now
really um
but i do
i guess there is a certain part of
you know uh being in this town where you
have to pretend to be confident in order
to survive don't let them see a weakness
you know what i mean and so
maybe there's a little bit of a
confident persona or maybe maybe it is
part of who i am
um but i
i like to uh
i think the best way to
professionally get
jobs is i mean the only way is to be
confident right i mean when you go on
audition for something as soon as you
start second guessing yourself the
audition is dead or the interview is
dead or the meeting is dead
so
i've i turned a corner on that
when
well
i was confident
when i was in the state and when we were
doing the state and mtv out of college
because i was with all my
buddies and we all
um you all helped each other out we all
helped each other out it was a safe
place so i i was around that and then i
came out here and was introduced to this
town in a
in a
not as friendly way i i replaced
somebody on a tv show and i worked with
some people
and um it was not
a pleasant experience and i lost my
identity
and you lost your identity that's a
strong phrase i lost who i was or how i
could
uh
survive in certain situations
professionally and i can i couldn't
figure out how to navigate
the
work environment and i suffered because
of it it was it was bad
and then when that ended oh no in the
middle of that in the middle of that
show i
got my
for lack of a better word you know
phrase i got my balls back and i
i wanted to say something about balls
and it was something i saw on tick tock
where people like somebody who's like
talking about balls and like women or
women women
they're everybody talks about like
calling somebody a vagina or a [ __ ]
and they're like that's a sign of
weakness whereas like a vagina and a
[ __ ] you're like
uh
so strong and like give life and do you
know like it couldn't be like right the
opposite of
the you know calling somebody that and
then balls when you say people have
balls
uh
says you know like that they're tough
but if you tap somebody's balls
they're the most fragile
that's so true it's such a it's a you
touch
the testicle yeah you're done clearly
men have come up with those two you know
definitions of those two ways of using
that as slang anyway um
so i got my i got my uh my my power back
but i want to know like that's to say
something like you lost your balls
or your vagina and then you got it back
yeah now the interesting part to me is
how the hell you got it back like what
what did you do to get it back
well i uh
i
i mean the truth is is i
got to a point where i couldn't i
couldn't deal with it anymore i couldn't
deal with like the chaos of like trying
to figure out how to
navigate uh without using the tools that
i knew i had
and i forgot that i had those tools for
a while and i'm like oh no
live or die by the tools that you have
um
and
at least then you go down
knowing that
you were true to yourself and then as
soon as that happened i stood up for
myself and i did the things that i
thought were funny and i did you know i
said the things that i needed to say to
the people that were sort of um
uh
not being kind and
[Music]
and then i turned a corner on that and
then
right soon after that what david and
showalter were doing wet hot
and i did on american summer it went out
american summer and i went and shot that
with them and i was with that group
again as as well as like paul and amy
and
brad and
uh uh everybody bradley cooper
everybody who worked on that and
i was like oh
this can exist
there are other people outside of the
state that are good kind positive
creative awesome people
i don't need to
suffer through working with people who
are not particularly kind
i can just work with people i like
and then
uh you know that
that shift and also um
kind of getting my
power back uh you know kind of
dovetailed into each other and since
then i guess i've had a
uh
you know
going with your observation i've been
more confident with how i approach uh
this business
and life
yeah i know that's that's interesting
that's a fantastic answer
i just feel like
there's times in my life where i feel
like i've lost it like i've lost that
confidence and you said something really
important
you said something
you know you have the tools
is it that for a while there you forget
about the tools that you have and you're
just
like almost like looking at your ugly
self and and thinking i can't do this
but then realizing wait a minute i can
do this i've done this before
well i mean i can only speak for you
know through
about my personal experiences of how it
happened and when i was doing the state
it was like being in a band and you know
you as you were together longer you sort
of you sort of have uh you've dug
a hole for yourself or you've you've
created a certain niche
part of the group or like a
section of
a
you've created
your personality within the group and
there was
at a certain point there's no
reversing that you can adjust but
there's no reversing it but i was who i
was in that group and i had
and i
for better for worse that's who i was
when i left that group
and by the way
the state was on a show
that well you guys created in college
you and david wayne and a bunch of other
guys yeah show waltz and these and it
aired on mtv from 93 to 95 and it was
this comic troupe and you did all these
skits and things for those of you yes we
were mtv and then right we we not broke
up we just stopped making money so
everybody had to go off and do their own
thing
um and
what was your question
about tools what was it what was it ryan
oh you started you were talking about
your personality within the group yeah
oh oh so i so uh i oh so when i left the
group i was like i'm not going to make
those mistakes that i made in the group
i'm going to start fresh right with new
people
and so
so
i had this mantra that was not
healthy ultimately i thought it was
healthy i'm going to be all things to
all people
right i'm going to approach this new
person and this new person and this new
person and not make the stupid mistakes
that i made in my college and early 20s
with the state
you know where i was young and i did
stupid things and then like
you know like or said stupid things or
got into fights with people for stupid
reasons i'm gonna do all things to all
people and in doing that i never stood
up for myself
and so
uh
so i lost my identity you were giving
too much to too many people perhaps i
was trying to
[Music]
be friendly with everybody and not worry
about
my feelings or who i was i was just
trying to be like okay oh is that will
that make you happy oh will that make
you happy um because
i just
you know left this group that i was with
for
five six years right
and i just wanted to start fresh and so
i thought that that was a good approach
it wasn't healthy for me and so
at a certain point i was like oh i don't
have to be all things to all people i
have to be true to myself and i have to
be kind to people and i have to try to
communicate as best i can but i don't
have to
not everybody has to be my friend
that's that's and that was the shift i
think for me that's a great
i mean when you're were you talking
about this i start to think this is kind
of therapy for me at times like this
there's with certain guests i'll tell a
story and i'll immediately they'll come
back to me and i go this this is helping
me this makes me understand because i
feel like i give a lot to people right
and a lot of people take and a lot of
people take and you are you always want
to appease everybody and make everybody
happy and you're not taking care of
yourself right but for you to have that
insight did you did you go to therapy
did you have a breakdown what was it i
had i broke down i went to therapy i you
know i had i it was i had moved from new
york and i came out here
and i was doing a show that i was a
regular on
and
it was an established show what was that
show it was men behaving badly and
behaving badly rob schneider uh yeah
yeah and
uh
and
i uh
i came out
and
yeah i don't know what to forget what i
was saying well you were just talking
about how you uh when you when you came
how it all shifted you started going to
therapy or whatever oh yeah yeah so it's
pretty soon after me coming out i was
like i might need to go see it talk to a
therapist
um i was also going through a
relationship thing so it was like there
was a lot of stuff that was going on in
my
life that i was uh
that i needed to speak to somebody about
and
and uh it helped
so from the time you you
made it through therap therapy i like
this stuff this is this is this is what
people like this is like how do you
because you get in ruts and how do you
get out of them well you went to therapy
you dealt with your anxiety you dealt
with like all these issues yeah because
if you did if you didn't go to therapy
you think you would have gotten through
it
on your
own i i don't know i have no idea i mean
probably
in some way
um yeah but i don't know do you still
get scared do you still get nervous do
you still get anxious
anything a new role
tackling something you know they say a
lot of times when an actor gets a role
they get uh they get a little anxiety
they get like i can't do this i can't do
this no what's his name was here uh emil
hirsch and he was like i get this
feeling i can't [ __ ] do it i don't
know how to do it and then [ __ ] he
figures it out no i don't get i don't
get anxiety about
a role that i get i go in i get if i get
something or something is given to me
um
through either an audition or a meeting
or just relationships that i have with
people
um i go in and i do what i think is the
right thing and
lately
um
you know as i've gotten older
i'm given the freedom to do those things
and
there's a trust
that um that's there with the people i'm
working with because i have a
relationship with them
uh you know i've worked with them on
other things but i don't get scared i'm
i'm just like
i
i i'm
i just there's a trust
that if i go
i never
if i go too far that they'll pull me
back
but i just i've i've decided that
it goes back to what i was saying before
which is like i just have to make some
choices
as an actor and do them and trust that
my choices are
uh
you know good and not second-guess
myself be 100 confident and then
if somebody doesn't like it they'll tell
me and if they don't say anything then
that's their issue right and then the
thing that i'm doing is going to be the
thing that i'm doing and i i
you know for the most part i'm gonna
enjoy that because it's
it's it's not um
there's no filter it's just coming
through me and
it's something that i think i can do
that somebody else can do but they're
going to have their version of that have
you ever been replaced yes you have
i've been replaced once too so i know
how that feels i was a guest on a on a
tv show uh just shoot me and they i was
a fireman and they replaced me
how did you take it
uh
i was waiting for that to happen at some
point in my career because everybody has
an experience like that so i was like
okay
i mean i you know i
i came up i there were reasons that i
was like i think i know why that
happened and then when i watched it i
was like yeah sure okay
it didn't bother me really no
i got paid you get paid well that's the
other thing is like i i don't know what
would
my dad was a plumber and a cesspool
cleaner and
my mom was a dog groomer and my dad
every time i talk to my dad the first
thing he asks me
i'm not saying this is healthy at all
you making money
like my dad's
uh approach to
work is like go out collect some money
bring it home and take care of your
family and go to sleep and wake up the
next day and do the same thing
i've always approached acting
like that which is
i need to make money to to i i love
acting and i love doing different things
and i love working on really great
projects
but i also like you know um hot water
and so
so
so i want to
you know um
ultimately
you know
make sure that i'm putting money in the
bank
so i can
hopefully do the things that i want to
do
more and more as i get older you know
you talk about that so it makes me think
of your childhood like what was your
childhood like with with your with your
parents were they was your dad always
like when you said i want to be an actor
i'm going to get in this comic troupe
yeah or whatever were they supportive
always supportive always supportive
always supportive he wasn't like hey no
got to bring home the bacon no
he's always supportive
everything you did they went to your
plays yep
i mean my dad came to plays when he
could but he was working he worked crazy
hours and so
he you know sometimes his days consisted
of waking up at six and rolling in at
nine o'clock at night or ten o'clock at
night because he was digging ditches and
pumping people's [ __ ] out of their
cesspools and
putting in sewer lines and like that's
what he would do
so he had an incredible work ethic
yeah yes i mean he worked really hard um
to take care of
uh
my family and you always looked at that
like that's always is was he a role
model would you say i think so i think
my dad is a i mean somebody i look up to
he's a flawed human being but are aren't
we all
but he's he's a great man and do you
when you look back you think you could
have done anything yeah have a drink
your tea your your coffee i'm sorry did
you hear my stomach
no do you have to shed no it's just that
there's nothing in there's no food in me
and i can't do i can't eat anything
until after my collap
colonoscopy colonic are you worried that
you um
might need to get up while you're doing
this interview i'm already i already
have to take a a a
a leak why don't you pee you know what's
interesting is there's another thing my
wife doesn't know it's interesting this
is another thing my wife and i talk
about i say to her
uh i gotta go i gotta go take a [ __ ] or
i gotta go pee and she's like you don't
have to
address it yeah just say you go to the
bathroom
i know what goes on in there i don't
like to miss anything ken i like to
leave the door open people don't always
like it much like bruno mars and
anderson puck really yeah they like to
leave the door open even when i'm
pooping
well i don't know if that lyrically well
i i oh is that a lyric
have you not heard that song no how does
it go it's [ __ ] great how's it going
ryan it says silk sonic
gonna leave the door open i'm gonna
leave the door oh then
leave the door open girl i'm gonna leave
the door oh ben i'm aging myself yeah
dude i should know this but this song
but it sounds like we didn't we did not
our version of it was not
it was whispered it was a little it was
a little creepy actually it was a little
sensual
i thought that was pretty good
i mean we sang on key i will say that
yeah yeah it was saying
which was nice and you weren't creepy i
just feel like i was creepy i was
quieter because i couldn't hear it like
really nice in the headphones oh am i
supposed to put on the headphones
you know try them you might like it you
might like listen you know that's the
best way it's more intimate i didn't
realize you weren't doing no i wasn't so
selling this whole time so let's start
over all right so uh you brought these
uh
you brought these things over these uh
tv guides listen i'm going to penis yeah
you should pee no no no
right now yeah
okay
a boy
is he really doing it
go pee all right
this episode is sponsored by blue chew
say it with us
blue chew blue chew is bringing more
confidence to the bedroom by offering
chewable tablets that can help men get
stronger and longer lasting erections i
call them boners they have the
professional term erections
it's true i don't care how old you are
we've all lost a boner folks blue chew
is a unique online service that delivers
the same active ingredients as viagra
and cialis but in chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost bluetooth tablets
help men achieve harder stronger
erections to combat all forms of ed
bluechu is an online prescription
service so no visits to the doctor's
office folks no awkward conversations
and no waiting in line at the pharmacy
and it ships right to your door in a
discreet package the process is simple
sign up at bluechew.com consult with one
of their licensed medical providers and
once you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
it's all done online blue chews licensed
medical providers work with you to find
the right ingredient and strength for
your prescription don't like swallowing
pills no problems here blue chews
sildenafil and tadalafil tablets are
chewable blue chews tablets are made in
the u.s of a and they prepare and ship
direct so it's cheaper than a pharmacy
so if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
visit
bluechew.com i know i do
and here's a special deal for our
listeners try bluetooth free when you
use our promo code inside at checkout
just pay five dollars shipping that's
bluechew.com promo code inside to
receive your first month
free and we thank bluechu for sponsoring
the podcast inside of you is brought to
you by my good friends at betterhelp
betterhelp online therapy this is
working i don't know how many people
have come up to me ryan at convention
saying i tried betterhelp it's really
saving my life it's really helping me
one of those people is helping is ryan
it's helping me it's a helpful service
and you get in the name help help better
help better help and you did you get a
new therapist uh i did um yeah just uh
just recently right because uh ryan had
a therapist and so he wanted another
therapist and so that's what happened
it's so easy better help online therapy
really has done a great job and i really
appreciate having them on the response
as a sponsor uh
they're just so fitting that's what we
do here we talk about a lot of things
depression anxiety look whether you're
struggling with grief relationships or
stress or you're having trouble sleeping
or meeting goals online therapy
might be for you
better help us secure online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with a licensed
professional therapist betterhelp will
assess your needs and match you with
your own accredited therapist you can
start communicating in under 48 hours
and you don't have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room
therapists have a broad range of
expertise which may not be available in
your area the service is available for
clients worldwide you can log into your
account anytime and send a message to
your therapist you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
it's really
amazing and easy and better help is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change therapists if you
need like ryan it's also more affordable
than traditional offline therapy and
financial aid is available i'm telling
you offline therapy is so much more
expensive coming from someone who has
gone through a lot of therapy i'm
telling you this is the way to go it's
easy visit
slash betterhelp.com
and join the over two million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional insider is sponsored by
betterhelp and our listeners get ten
percent off their first month of online
therapy at betterhelp.com
slash inside that's better help
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash inside better help online
therapy try it folks inside of you is
brought to you by chilly sleep listen to
this guys science tells us that the best
way to achieve and maintain consistent
deep sleep is by lowering core body
temperature
temperature controlled sleep restores
testosterone levels repairs muscle after
a hard day's work and improves cognitive
function so you always start your day
feeling sharp and alert
chili sleep makes customizable climate
controlled sleep solutions that help you
improve your entire well-being chili
sleep makes the ooler and cube sleep
systems hydro powered temperature
controlled mattress toppers that fit
over your existing mattress to provide
your ideal sleep temperature
these luxury mattress pads keep your bed
at the perfect temperature for deep
sleep whether you sleep hot or cold
these sleep systems are designed to help
you fall asleep stay asleep and give you
the confidence and energy to power
through your day you know for me since
using chili sleep i i usually
you know sleeping is first of all the
mattress is the most important thing but
if you're sleeping
if you can cool your body down it's the
most important thing it really is it's
incredibly important and as for you know
for things that we talk about in here
like increasing testosterone and other
things but um
sleep is the most important thing in the
world folks and um if you're not getting
a good night's sleep you're missing out
because you're not being the best you
chilly sleep
helps imagine waking up and not feeling
tired folks chilly sleep can help make
that happen for an extra layer of
comfort they also make the chili blanket
the only weighted blanket that can also
be paired with a control unit for the
ultimate sweat free sleep
i mean i'm telling you this thing works
i like to sleep cold ryan and anything
that makes me sleep cold and lowers my
body temperature the core temperature i
mean you see all the results that happen
when you when you sleep in a colder uh
temperature it works um look
don't don't take my word for it just go
do it just go do it all right head over
to chilisleep.com
iou to learn more and check out a
special offer available exclusively for
inside of you listeners and for only a
limited time that's chile
c-h-i-l-i sleep.com
iou to take advantage of our exclusive
discount and wake up refreshed every day
c-h-i-l-i chilisleep.com
iou
so spaulding gray
wrote a
book swimming in cambodia
well he did a he did a one-man show and
he also wrote a book about that that's
right but he but prior to that book he
wrote a book called i think
sex and death by the age of 14 or
something like that
um
something like that right
and in it i remember there's a a little
section where he had a girl over his
house
and he would go into the bathroom and he
knew that you can hear
the person peeing the person outside can
he
hear when he was peeing in the in the
toilet right so he would take
um like a pitcher of water and pour it
in so it was a stronger flow
so it sounded like he had a stronger
flow to the girl outside
[Laughter]
and i always thought well why i think
maybe because that that implied that he
had a like a
bigger a bigger dick yeah i don't know
that's kind of odd
well look it made for a great story
for him not not necessarily for this
podcast do you embarrass easily i i
would tell you you don't
want to be embarrassed what embarrasses
you
i don't know
you really don't know anything that
embarrasses you
like not not uh [ __ ] up on set not
getting your lines out not being able to
uh be as great as you thought you were
oh so you're talking about like
professionally professionally or
unprofessionally like you know things
that embarrass you like you know i don't
like being
called out i don't i mean i don't know i
i could be sensitive but i i'm pretty
good with it you know i used to get
really mad people go you don't listen
you don't listen
and finally i just said i accepted that
why don't you think i mean do you agree
with that do you agree that you don't
think i have uh selective hearing
i think that i listen when someone
really needs to tell me something
or it's uh i'm engaged
or i have these headphones on and i'm
talking to someone i'm able to focus
have a little add
so
if it's a lot of nonsense if you're
talking to a person for hours on end
about you know whatever spending the day
with them and they're kind of like
sometimes they'll say something they'll
be chirping i'll be chirping mm-hmm i
don't always hear it
but in in this situation do you check
out do you find yourself checking out or
you see you seem pretty on top of it no
i'm pretty on top of it i'm on point for
the most part i like i i you're you're
engaging i have these head like i said i
put the head on don't you feel now that
you put the cans on you feel a little
more like you're engaged
sure i mean what i feel like is i can
hear every
noise i make which is
i guess maybe that's
that's how i get embarrassed i don't
want to hear my bodily like my clicks
enough
i'm like my stomach do you like watching
yourself
uh on on
film
i
i always like to watch whatever i do
uh the first time by myself
and then i'll watch it a couple of times
and then i have no problem watching with
other people so if so that embarrasses
me if i'm watching something i've never
seen the final result of like you know
like a thing that i've done with my
flies open no one can see that your
waist down oh look at that well i see it
yeah it's good for you um
if i watch something that i've never
seen before
that i've that i've been in
with other people that that i get
uncomfortable
i always want to see what i what what
what the cut is you want to be the judge
yeah of who sees it so no i want to see
what they i want to see what takes they
use i want to see how they did it i want
to see how the how the piece looks and
then i can say
yeah i'll watch that with you or you can
watch that by yourself have you been
disappointed with
your work at all in your lifetime
of course yeah haven't you
oh yeah sure yeah
i mean i always do the best i can and i
always feel like
you know i'm gonna give it all i have
and sometimes you're always it just
depends on there's so many variables you
know
for instance smallville
if i was really good on a really crappy
show it wouldn't matter
no one would care
all the pieces have to fall in line the
show has to be good the writing has to
be good right the acting is good all
these things have to be so most the time
it's a disappointment because a lot of
those things usually don't make it
does that make sense well i mean so you
watch something that you're
that you felt good about your
performance and then you watched the
whole thing and you're like well i
didn't like that whole thing so i don't
like my performance probably
i don't i don't know because i'm part of
it
i i will watch something where i didn't
i didn't i don't like how it came out
like the show the tone or the approach
to the show and i watch what i did and
sometimes i'm like oh i like that they
use that stuff or
i still feel good about what i did or
sometimes i'm like oh wow it was cut
together where they pulled all the stuff
that i thought was interesting out yeah
so it it varies i always know notice
that you
you really commit you either cause you
can do drama you're adept to comedy and
drama i mean you've done drama do you by
the way do you prefer drama over comedy
you just like acting in general i just
like acting
you'll do whatever they tell you to do
yeah
i think i don't think there's a big
difference between drama and comedy
really i think comedy here's the thing i
think drama is easier
but i think comedy's harder because it's
so many takes and it's so many to get
the right timing and everything we're
drama you just
as long as you're real and grounded not
to say well but that's the thing i think
in comedy you have to be real and
grounded the stakes are higher right the
importance of like
for me like my approach is like you know
you know if we're talking about like
whatever
party down party down i'm talking about
party now right uh you know ron donald
is
a guy who
i mean
everything every choice he makes it's
all important to him and so
i think it's
uh
played
it's played to be real through the
character that he is
do i make some do i try to make some
comic choices in there some
physicalities or like different things
like
within a scene sure but like
my hope is that it's always
grounded and real
makes sense was was party then did you
think it was going to be successful when
you guys were doing it
did you have any idea do you ever know
really
uh
no
i mean i i knew it was a special show i
knew the people that i was working with
were
like talented and special and good
people and there wasn't there was a
an energy that
i liked and i hoped that it would be
successful because
uh
i like being around that
energy and how many seasons did you do a
party down we did two
just two seasons
yeah i thought it was more than that it
was for stars uh which nobody had at the
time
it only got a following
it would like netflix had just started
and they had put out the seasons on
netflix but at that but by that point uh
it was already a
um a sinking ship
but supposedly they're bringing this
back yes
supposedly
well do you know the answer
yeah supposedly
and what
what's what are they going to do
supposedly uh a season another like a
season for stars is supposedly and how
exciting i mean they were working on a
movie at one point i don't think that's
happening
but it's it's uncanny it's just this
doesn't happen a lot a show airs two
seasons
and then they want to bring it back
well i mean that's just that's a rarity
i've been on a lot of shows that last
one season two seasons they don't five
years how long was the rest of
development on
three seasons right what was it four it
was three and then they brought it back
from four or five yeah
like i said it's a rarity look i hope
they bring it back i don't i can't also
you're not you can't divulge i don't
know i mean i i i know they've always
talked about it and it's a possibility
and you want to do it of course
any chance to get to work with those
guys again is a gift
you know you know how it is you work
with like a lot of people that you know
or people that you enjoy
spending time around and creating with
that's it goes back to what i was saying
about hot american summer as soon as i
realized oh
you know
this is this is special and rare and
but something that i can strive for and
try to
be immersed in as much as possible
that's that's all i try to do i try to
work with people i enjoy and
and whose uh
comic sensibilities i appreciate and
respond to and then
sometimes the stuff is successful
sometimes it's not but ultimately i
think it's
always interesting and good
did you level up did you think what hot
american summer would have been the cult
classic that it's become no but that's
another you know show where like we shot
it and we're like
who we don't care if anybody watches
this we know it's funny
and it was all your friends
it's like you're going to camp with all
your friends that's what we did we
stayed at a camp for uh
you know seven weeks or six weeks and we
all just stayed at at this uh camp uh
during the off season it was great and
you just did what you wanted in in a
sense like you do a take uh did david
just sort of say i mean didn't you
co-write it i did not show all he and
show walter and show walter so when
they're doing these when they're filming
are you
able to
improvise do they want you to stick to a
script they go give me a ken take give
me a big i mean back then it was david's
first movie he was directing a lot of us
was our first movie that we were in and
you know much like any i mean there
wasn't a lot of time to improvise a lot
because it was a short short schedule
and ambitious and um but yeah of course
you know everybody sort of
tried different things but um the script
you know everybody stuck to the script
at first and
tried to honor that when you watch it
now when's the last time you saw it
i think i watched it with my son who's
14 recently and then he watched the
series and so maybe within the last year
i don't know if i watched the whole
thing what did he think he loved it or
he i think he really liked it i think he
appreciated
yeah it's just a classic do you just not
love that movie
it really is
so many great characters in that who's
your fav who's who's your favorite who's
your like what's the one moment in that
movie or the one character that just
kicks your ass that just makes you laugh
every time you see it him or her i mean
maloney's fantastic i like the
relationship between maloney and 80
miles i think that's great um
uh i like me and joe i like joe and
larry i like when joe and i get to do
stuff together yeah i think there's fun
stuff in the
series that joe and i get to do that
makes me laugh do you know what my
favorite one of my favorite moments in
that movie is
uh it's well when i crash into the tree
hilarious that's what we're gonna say
yes it's one of the best movies you know
what another one is
is showalter going yes in the dinosaur
in the when he was uh
uh
i was so old that pterodactyls were
there or whatever what the hell was his
name oh my god yeah he just killed me
look i look at historical like your
resume you've done i mean you've done so
much [ __ ] like when i say [ __ ] i mean
like the [ __ ] not [ __ ]
i mean sure you've done [ __ ] we've all
done [ __ ] sure but like will and grace
angel reno911 grey's anatomy monk happy
endings
uh red hot american summer party down uh
wonderlust you co-wrote wonderlust right
i did uh
the other two is now on
the other two has been on uh the first
season came out i'm gonna watch it
because ryan just told me about it now i
gotta watch that oh yeah you gotta see
the other two it's great yeah i can't
wait that's a great tell me tell me the
premise it's about so it's about you
know like
you know the um
there's this
overnight success this
14 year old boy
becomes an overnight success
uh on you know youtube sensation like a
justin bieber type kid and uh
you know becomes a star overnight
but it's not about him it's about his
older brother and sister who are
struggling in new york and experiencing
his rise to fame so quickly and their
relationship and molly shannon is the
mom the midwest mom who comes out uh to
uh chaperone him and watch him and i'm
the manager who gloms on who considers
himself family but uh isn't
i can imagine
i can't wait to watch it i'm going to
watch it yeah you should watch that i
think that yeah what else should i watch
well have you ever seen burning love i
haven't yes i saw one episode i really
enjoyed that you should watch burning
love i think my wife and i wrote that my
wife wrote that and created that and i
directed it and uh we did three seasons
and they're short little quick seasons
um but i'm super proud of that burning
love how hard is it to write and work
with your wife easy i mean it was i
didn't write she wrote it and then i
directed it and was in it and it was
great it was one of the
most incredible experiences of uh
my
professional life how do you keep things
sane in the house how do you keep a
happy marriage when you're both in the
business and you're both working
together and you're both on top of each
other's [ __ ] all the time
i think you try to communicate as
healthy as possible i think you just try
to
like
talk about the things that are
clearly there and if something comes up
that's
you know it's not really about that you
say well it's not really about that
right it's about this so let's talk
about that and let's work through it
i mean that's not all easy no ways no
nothing's easy no you recommend me
getting married
to whom i mean i'm just in general do
you recommend marriage i don't think you
need to get married and but if you want
to get married i think you should get
married do you think people should only
get married if they're gonna have kids
no i don't think kids i don't
think it's about kids i think i think if
you want to
have a ceremony where you're committing
yourself to somebody and you want
everybody to celebrate and you want to
call it marriage then you should do it
whether or not you're having kids
but you don't have to to commit yourself
to somebody
you hear that ryan yeah
what do you think ryan what do i think
do you think i'm ever gonna get married
i don't know if you find the right
person
i mean are you dating anybody right now
no not right now
do you want to get married or do you
feel that it just seems something your
family or something i mean every time
you see my grandmother she's like when
are you gonna have kids you'd be such a
great dad when are you gonna do this you
hear it all the time and you see your
friends that are couples and they're
doing all these things together and you
spend a lot of
nights alone you do right there's a lot
of time when you're alone right and then
you immerse yourself in work and the
next thing you're working too much and
then you're spending the nights alone
and you're like you know
um but you don't want to get into that
old
little [ __ ] where you just start seeing
girl after girl and you know just uh you
know because that happened
right and it's just they're filling the
void you know in a sense you're both
like
maybe
you're both alone so it's like oh what's
i don't know i mean i think that you
should just uh
just live your life every day and then
if you find somebody you want to
spend a lot of time with then do that
why are you going to get married for
your grandma don't get married for your
grandma by the way you know it's funny
you know what let you agree
you know what you see your grandma how
many times a year
twice a year twice a year and you're
going to get married
because you you graham you talk to her
twice a year
and you're gonna i'm no i'm mad you know
what i told her what did you tell her i
said
blanc
i said
here's what's going to happen i'm going
to get married and finally have a kid
and you're going to die and she said
don't call me blanc yeah
you just tell your grandmother she's
gonna die i mean i'm sure she knows it i
say that to her she always sings the
song the old mare ain't what she used to
be
what she used to be she's always
complaining then she's gonna die and
she's gonna die
you know when you do all these things
this is good therapy for me when you do
all these episodics all these things
yeah
were you
did you just like working or were you
like when am i gonna get my [ __ ]
chance when am i gonna get why am i not
gonna do a guest star did you go through
those stages of because it is not easy
by the way the hardest part of being an
actor i think well not working but then
that's the hardest part but being a
guest star is the second hardest
because you're coming into a show that's
already established and then you you're
just jumping in there yeah
i think that's the hardest did you like
doing guest stars yeah you did yeah i
don't i i mean i i i i didn't feel that
way i don't feel that way when i do a
guest spot i feel like especially
later but like
you know i mean the worst
the
worst part about it is
they shoot the actors out and then you
have like one or two takes before lunch
or one or two takes before you wrap at
the end of the day
um for your coverage but um when i
realized that i just would do
again it goes back to what i was saying
i just do what i i just do what i
ultimately would want to land on as
opposed to like
you know
shuffling up hedging up to to to the
edge or you know creeping up to the edge
and being like
will anybody want to see me make these
choices i just go in and do those
choices and then
if they don't like it then they can make
the adjustment on the next take which is
the second take and the only other take
i'll get in the shot
but um the point is is i don't i like
doing guest spots i don't feel a lot of
pressure doing it i enjoy it
if they want me to come on their show
and i'm lucky enough to be a guest on
their show i'm gonna have a good time
you just you really love work you love
acting
i do don't you
i don't know
i don't know man i i don't know if i
love it as much i think it's it's a it's
a lot of
look i'm very grateful i've talked about
this a million times i if it's something
i do or i create or it's part of like
you know with your friends like you say
that could be great i'm very excited
about that but there's also something
about shooting a scene
a two-page scene in six hours
yeah over and over and over again why
what i don't think that's fun oh see i
see i have a very different feeling tell
me about that
i mean i do it i'm pleasant and i and
i'm very fun and i like but i but i
don't and i can enjoy it
but it's not like everyone thinks people
come to see me on set and i'm doing
something and they're like holy [ __ ]
you're doing this again right and i get
it i'm like yeah doing it again i guess
my my feeling is i have
my approach to it is
99 of the time you're not acting right
and so when you get the opportunity to
act when you're given text and you're
giving a a
a platform or a place to do it with
cameras rolling or people watching um
then you get then then and you get to do
it a bunch of times that's fun because
you can bend it in different directions
you can give a bunch of different
options you're giving i'm thinking about
like the editor getting
17 different
options of what might work
and
it's fun for me
um
uh to
have the opportunity to
play with something and be like what's
another way that that within the
confines of like what the scene is and
you know honoring the script and
honoring the the character and serving
the story where you're supposed to
what's another way i can bend this and
so
a lot of takes is i enjoy a lot of takes
i hear you i i'm just saying i think
that over the years ken i think i really
did enjoy it i i just threw myself into
it and then something happened where i'm
like
i don't know maybe i got a little jaded
maybe i got a little bit like
i don't know
you know even ryan will tell me i'm
supposed to do this maybe this movie i'm
very blessed he's like do it get your
feet wet again get in get get in there
fall in love again you have to do it
i know you really think you know and
it's not that i i look i
i like acting
i think i do okay job
i i just
maybe i've been on some things that i'm
just like uh that was just too much
[ __ ] work and it just wasn't the
greatest payoff well that's that's why
that's you know but that's the paycheck
part of it like you got paid you got
paid and then you you
you get to appreciate
those
moments for me would be like party down
or burning love or wet hot american
summer or like you know pounding down
like things that i get to do that are
special
and i appreciate those and value those
even more and i and i can say wow i got
to do that
and then the other stuff is like
paychecks i'm collecting the paycheck
you know it's funny and i'm also
working out i'm i'm working out the
whatever the process well it's you know
the acting muscle or whatever
i'm getting to
act and do stuff and sometimes it's
gonna be uh you know
you get thrown out at first and
sometimes it's gonna be uh you know a
nice little
extra bass uh hit
you know what i would have done and i
would have been excited and i would have
done
i would have worked
any hours to do
um was do eastbound and down no and this
guy tested for it against me and i read
with danny and they said it's between
you and one other guy
and they went with you oh was it me yeah
and i go oh [ __ ] i love ken but that
[ __ ] that's the one i wanted i
remember going in sorry about that no
but i remember you know and we hit it
off and um he came up to me at a table
read for something else he goes man you
were [ __ ] funny we were going to cast
you but you were right up there man you
were right up there with that with the
guy we go yeah candy's like yeah ken's
great but you were right up there too
just want you to know you were really
funny and he was cool that's always nice
to hear that yes what a treat did you
improvise the [ __ ] out of that
there i mean you know they had a script
but yeah every scene
was
uh you know they opened we we opened it
up i think i mean i
definitely
threw in a lot of stuff can that be
intimidating
working with someone like danny mcbride
i mean you're going toe-to-toe with him
and you did it and you nailed it but
like he's a he's a wizard right yeah
he's incredible he just goes were you
just shot like how funny was he
on his side always funny but always
grounded oh he's real like he never says
anything that doesn't feel like it's you
know just going back to the drama and
the comedy like
he's saying you know what when he would
say it it it was
you know grounded and real and
and yeah it was funny but it was
it can't you know felt
it felt uh
like sure this it was
there was comedy in to it but it was
um real how always seems real how often
did you break i don't remember because i
think mcbride is honestly one of my top
favorite comedians he's the best like i
just like
it just i don't know how i would like i
mean i guess when you're on set you just
got to stay in
it seems like you've done worked around
so many you've been you hear that was
that that was weird no oh what's gone
now oh was it an earthquake what do we
got
but there's maybe it's your stomach
i didn't hear at that time but maybe but
you've worked with so many great
comedians you've been around them you've
you've worked with everybody a ton of
top-notch improvisational comedians so
there's probably not a lot that makes
you laugh anymore you seem like someone
that just was staying character and
you're hard to break is that something
is that true
i don't i don't think i break a lot no
i don't think i break a lot
i think you break when you're not
when you're not fully
the person that you're doing
i think like when you're watching
yourself you you break more than when
you when you're
really connected to the person because
whatever the person says
you know uh you should
try to respond to it in a in a real way
through that character that you're
playing but you know sometimes
something you know i i i can't always
get to that place so yeah i guess i
break sometimes
i don't know but don't you like it don't
you like it when you break every once in
a while i like watching other people
break i i've been watching um a lot of
bloopers of uh always sunny
and my god first of all i love those
guys and i think that their show is i
had fun i got to do an episode i really
enjoyed it oh what did you do i did um
gun control it was like the first season
i was i played um her uh boyfriend
what's her name dee yeah dee's boyfriend
who comes into town yeah it was really
fun i mean you know watching them and
watching watching
them break each other up is
it it's like it's like a
it keeps coming up on my tick tock
and i'm like oh great give me more give
me more bloopers of them so you like
seeing other people [ __ ] up i like
seeing other people enjoy
each other and laugh
jimmy fallon was that no too much
no jimmy fallon he used to break up on
setting it live like every every time
every time yes did that bother you some
people thought he's breaking up come on
i always thought it was funny when he
was he was always [ __ ] up
i mean you know it was fine i liked when
uh uh rachel dratch
would
break up in debbie in the debbie downer
sketch that i enjoyed that more when
it's a main when when the main character
breaks on snl and there's no
resetting
that's more funny to me than the person
who's sort of
peripherally in the scene
right she's she's the lead in the scene
yeah and then she has to get through it
and everybody else is trying to keep it
together for her
and she can't
do it that's that's when i really enjoy
it how do you like directing
i love it because you directed a couple
episodes of the goldbergs
i directed one or two one one but i've
i've directed some features and i've
directed uh children's hospital i've
directed children's hospital you're
looking at my imdb page no what are you
looking at well there's just notes i
took oh
well i just looked at you directly and
i'm gonna tell you i did two features
that uh i enjoyed directing and i
directed all of burning love those are
the things you direct all of burning
love
and how do you like that what what is it
that you love about direct
you have
you see the
you know you see the whole picture and
you get to control the
elements and you get to control the tone
of the set you get to
uh i love
i love actors so i love talking to
actors about acting and comedy that's
so much fun
and to try to mold something into what
your vision of something is
is um
you know it's pretty pure i find it very
difficult when you're in a lot of it to
direct like i choose like my next choice
would not to be
uh
the lead role in something in a feature
or or a major role an integral part of
something i'd like to sit back and just
watch and observe and direct as opposed
to
being in it that i always felt like when
bradley cooper directed uh what was it
called the star is born star wars i'm
like amazed
well i guess my feeling is is
you're cutting out the middleman like
you're the director and the actor so you
know how to modulate it to where you
want to go
the cameras don't have to you don't have
to yell cut you don't have to pull the
actor's side and be like okay now i want
you to do that you're just [ __ ] doing
it
and you're on you know that you're in
front of the camera and you're the
director so nobody could say oh no i'm
going to cut you just keep rolling i'm
going to do that again like you actually
you have more control if you can kind of
bounce back and forth between seeing it
and being in it
and
um the only time i found it to be hard
to direct and act in something at the
same time is when it's a big group scene
because you're thinking about like how
are you covering right did i cover that
am i what's the best way to cover that
who's on camera have to have someone
have your back like watch your course
you know because you can't go back and
watch everything with that you're in you
got to kind of trust yourself
and trust the people that are watching
yes but you know when you give a good
performance right i think so i mean
there was times when there were times
when i i directed and i remember uh
thinking it was good and then well this
producer is like
uh your energy's just really low and i'm
like
that's because i haven't slept in two
months
but you're right and then i would do it
again you know i needed somebody to have
my back because i probably would have
gone like i felt pretty good
right i was asleep but i didn't realize
it well so did you direct what i mean
this little raunchy comedy called back
in the day it was like 2013. it was like
schwarzen marina backroom harlan
williams bunch of people it was it was
fun that's great yeah i was in the
middle of nowhere and uh
great time in my life but also i
regret like i shouldn't have been the
lead in it i would have enjoyed it much
more if i was not the lead in it did you
cre did you write it yeah
so you wrote it you're like i'm going to
direct this puppy yes i'm going to be in
it and my brother kept saying you're jim
you're [ __ ] jim man you got to be jim
i mean jim i'm like [ __ ] i wish i
wouldn't listen to my brother i didn't
know what the [ __ ] he was talking about
well stop listening to your brother stop
listening to your grandmother and just
live your life well you stopped trying
to appease everybody ken i did many
years ago
you just stopped yeah he said i'm not
gonna do this i'm and it's guilt that i
feel when someone says oh yeah hey i
haven't seen you in a while or they text
me you don't always have to text back
right you don't always have to send
emails back you don't i think that's my
problem is i always have to just
mine's looking at me like but i always
feel like i just have to make everybody
happy still and i gotta [ __ ] stop
that uh here's my thing about emails
i think that they're called emails and
so it's like mail
and so for me
mail sits on my [ __ ] desk and i don't
open it for
for months
so all of a sudden i got it like when
people get mad at me for not responding
to an email i'm like it's email it's
mail smail i don't look at it all the
time it's male sometimes i don't look at
it for like six months it's like a
seinfeld bit this is genius
now i say if you want me text me then i
see it's immediate i'll respond
i'm gonna start doing that
i don't know i don't know if it's
healthy but that's what but i always
like to delete my emails right away
i like to make you so there's not many
there
and i have folders and they just go in
those folders disappear pretty much and
then you never look at them again but
you have those folders but i have those
folders this is called [ __ ] talk
well that's sort of that's sort of like
my tv guides
oh yeah yeah i just keep them but i'm
never going to look at them never going
to look at them well we looked at them
today we sure did i'm very excited it
was a great gift you brought gifts you
brought coffee
mm-hmm very strong coffee this last
segment is called ken marino it's [ __ ]
talking with ken marino these are all my
patrons people who love the podcast
people who uh give it extra the podcast
go to patreon.com inside of you if you
want to join
it's awesome but these are quick rapid
fire
that means you mean like answer quickly
you you can don't have diarrhea
you can you can do whatever you want
lee well uh
emily asks favorite role you've done so
far in your career the one role that
years ago that was my favorite role i i
get this
sophie's choice i'll tell you some of
them give me top three burning love
uh
uh um
uh love
wet hot
uh oh
i mean and party down
there you go three i like ron donald
uh victor pulak and
uh mark orlando michelle k who's your
absolute favorite comedian you've worked
with i know that's hard
but like the one that you just go god i
just [ __ ] love that well i mean
somebody i'm in of like
and their skills and their talents i
mean you know danny mcbride is we just
talked about him he's you know i think
he's
incredibly special he really is yeah i
love that guy but i mean i've worked
with a lot of really incredible funny
people betsy d how much fun did you have
working on axe cop with nick offerman
i loved working on axe cop i loved the
original uh uh graphic novel i guess you
would call it uh my son and i would read
it together and i was um
excited when they started doing it and i
reached out and i said please
can i you know
read for axe cop and they're like nick
offerman's doing it
but you can be a flute cop and i said
great and then
i would go into a studio and do the
voice so i never saw nick when i was
doing it but i know nick and he's a he's
a fantastic guy
kelly s is there a particular actor
actress that you would love to work with
in the future that you haven't worked
with
there's
so many
so many people that i'd like to work
with i can't think of anyone in
particular i just want to keep working
with really good people
leanne p what advice would you give
yourself
a younger self if you had to give advice
to a younger self what would it be if
you could go back in time giving advice
to my younger self and my younger self
want to be an actor
just in in general
well okay well oh uh um no sudden
movements
and um
stop looking for it and you'll find it
stop looking for it and you're you'll
find it see that's directly to make it
right that's what just happened it just
went right to me lastly joe latruglio
from um brooklyn nine-nine you guys have
done tons of stuff without americans
right state but he didn't he didn't
bring you anything he didn't bring me
[ __ ] he didn't bring you and he's not a
damn thing he didn't bring you a coffee
nothing
he didn't want youtube
he did no no tv from the 70s and 80s
nothing
he did bring me a story though and i
love this story
set it up
go ahead tell me the story about when
you're doing when you're doing the pot
you're doing a pilot and joe comes to
see you
and i don't know i i can't believe this
happened but it just the story killed me
i the so after the state uh joe and i
came out here for pilot season i had i
booked a pilot it was called house
broken
it was me
it was three brothers who
move into their parents uh uh house
um because the parents retired and went
to florida and so it was me i was the
bachelor i was like the ladies man
um sean astin and his wife and i'm
forgetting the woman's name
but sean aston was like the you know
uptight like keeping everything
organized and mark ruffalo
um as the kind of wacky
the wacky uh brother
like the good cast and we
shot it and my first scene i i
oh maybe and it's a live studio audience
right yeah i think that this is it or it
might have been actually might have been
memory having badly now i'm [ __ ] but
just go with this one anyway so i asked
joe to come to the audience and and
watch
and because joe and i have have worked
on the state together i come in and i do
a scene and that's all you told them to
do is just sit there and watch yeah just
come to the show no but but then i come
in and i do the first take of the scene
and
it's a short little scene my entrance i
come in i say a couple things and it's
like cold open or something
and they cut
and then i turn to joe and i'm like
you know while they're setting the
cameras up you look at them like you
like it i'm running i'm like what do you
well i'm i was sort of asking like
good was it okay yeah yeah i was like it
was all right
and he goes
he goes
he does like a turning of a knob he's
like down he goes turn it
up
he goes he goes no he goes i'm sorry the
first thing he goes is he goes
mezzametze you know he does that hand
thing
he goes
and i was like
uh
and i froze
and i got inside my head and i was like
oh [ __ ] what i did sucked and then um
and then and then uh i i um
have given him [ __ ] about that you've
never invited him to a table you know
you're sure no longer i mean holy [ __ ] i
couldn't imagine i'd get in my head if i
looked after my friend like like oh not
bad he's like he's like man turn it up
just a little bit you're okay you're
okay turn it up dude it could be worse i
i would i would middle up middle that
would freak
oh my god well this has been a real
treat man my truth i really enjoyed this
you you helped me in many ways you
you've entertained
in many ways i'm excited about your
colonoscopy tomorrow we sang we did you
saying we did this has been a real treat
and ryan was excited about you being on
here and he's not excited about a lot of
guests oh i was a huge party down fan oh
um thank you ryan no i mean i i will i
just have to say like my favorite scene
was um
because like what you were saying about
uh like comedy like you
playing it truthful is the best way to
do it and that is just like any anyone
who teaches comedy will tell you that
like you it's not just saying the
ridiculous thing it's believing the
ridiculous thing right
and ron was just so that because every
catering event was the most important
thing it really was my favorite one was
the one when you did the the flag the
flag the young the the
because so because you got because ron
got put in charge of this like battle
worn uh american flag um i think josh
was josh gad josh
he gave it to you and you were like this
is the most important thing and then
martin starr's character got barbecue
sauce on it
and then you put in the washer put in
the washer all the colors ran
and just everything was so all
altruistic and then it the episode ends
with you
uh pulling a flying flag down in the
parking lot and setting it on fire and
they're all watching and then because
you're trying to make it look like it
did in the battle and it was just and
that like at that moment i was like oh
my god this is one of the this is the
funniest thing yes
a character that you like it's it's over
the top in ways but really once you
continue to watch it it's not it's so
grounded in that's who that guy is
and he's got to keep everybody on their
feet like what are you doing i told you
not to go in the [ __ ] room get out of
the room what are you just like this is
wound up it's all wound up yeah yeah and
it works the more you watch it the more
you get because you have to be that guy
you have to i mean i've seen that guy
anyway thank you for being here
this is a real treat it was my treat i
appreciate you inviting me yeah anytime
you're always welcome especially if you
bring treats uh always bring treats all
right thanks ken thank you
loved it guy makes me laugh knows how to
make folks laugh he's got a knack for it
that's for sure i want to thank you guys
again for listening if you were here for
ken marino please subscribe make sure
you subscribe uh we're everywhere um
apple stitcher spotify you can watch on
youtube make sure you subscribe tell all
your friends
our handles are at insightypodcast on
instagram and facebook at insideepot on
the twitter all the places mm-hmm my god
if you haven't watched party down please
go watch it party down so it's only two
seasons you can burn through it and burn
through it god this guy's so funny he is
funny uh and i will be in denver october
30th and 31st with tom welling you know
clark kent will be there signing
autographs so make sure you're in denver
colorado october 30th and 31st it's
gonna be a lot of fun uh
without my lovely patrons which i always
talk about who i always talk about i
couldn't do this podcast and i'm gonna
give a shout out to all my top tiers
right now
uh if you're a top tier you get your
name shouted out in the podcast so uh
join patreon patreon.com
inside of you that's right that's right
here we go
nancy
d leah s trisha f sarah v little lisa
you kiko jill e brian
h mama lauren g nico p
they didn't even give me a p jerry w
robert b jason w apothea and kristen k
amelia oh allison el raj c joshua d
emily s cjp samantha m jennifer
d n and stacey l gen s jamal f janelle b
carrie b tab of the 272 nothing to be
confused
kimberly e mike el don sopremo 99 more
99 more ramirez santiago am sarah f chad
w leanne p janine r maya p yes matty s
shannon d belinda and kevin v james r
chris h dave h spiderman chase sheila g
brad d ray h hi ray hi tabitha t liliana
a turd
k what was it again
yeah turd ferguson turd ferguson funny
name michelle michael s talia m betsy d
claire m laura l chad l rochelle nathan
e marion meg cage nlp trav l dan n
lorraine g carrie h veronica k big
stevie w kendall t angel m rhiannon c
cory k super sam nice
coleman
uh uh coolers g g
dev nixon michelle a liz
i is it just a hi
yeah are you sure it's an i yeah it's
got to be yeah i don't know i don't
think so i don't think that they're
doing lowercase was their music playing
yeah the whole time
i don't think you'd hear that podcast
right
jeremy c andy t cody r sebastian k
gavinator and h david c elliott m john b
brandy d avoir
camille s bano bono bano
the
c
joey m willie f christina e adelaide and
jeffrey m bridget a omar what's up omar
i think that's an l
lena n and design otg here look at this
right here look
i'm telling you that's an l because if
you look at michelle there's an l
well it would be a capital l
but it wouldn't you think it would be
the rest of the letters are cast so
that's omar i then
that's all i have to say about that
please let him know
thank you so much for tuning in week in
week out it makes me feel real good
whether you love the guests whether you
don't know the guests stay tuned you'll
learn something i sure as hell do uh
from the hollywood hills and california
i'm michael rosenbaum i'm ryan teyez and
uh we love you a little wave to the
camera and uh thank you all for allowing
me to be inside of you and have a
glorious week be good to yourselves
alright
you gotta be good to yourselves all
right we'll talk to you
[Music]